[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man what's wrong honey
it's our prop master bill I'm worried
about him he's he's a grown man and look
at him he's playing with trucks
well that truck is a prop and Bill is
the prop master he's just doing his job
he's playing with my old trucks this
house is so weird
why are we even living with the prop
master I hate it here and I hate you dad
Travis No
great now Travis is mad well he's always
mad I don't know what's with him I don't
have time for this I need to talk to
Bill oh honey go easy on him
hey Bill there buddy how's it going hey
: it's good to see you here get off the
floor bring your truck with you I want
to talk to you okay
why don't we step out here back with
this benches let's sit here on this
bench okay cuz well bill we've needed to
have a talk for a while you see I think
it's time for a change bill I know I'm
busy all the time with the show and not
around a lot I know this may be hard for
you to take but bill I think it's time
we put you in a home Oh retirement home
with with TV and jello well sure they
have those things there yeah I guess and
I hear that they have all these although
all the old people bunnies
the cue card bill says bang like bunnies
[Music]
but you see that's one of the reasons I
got to put you in a home okay I'd say
I'm getting laid by
did I hear you right you're putting bill
in a home yeah I told him but he took
the news just fine I got all I need
[Applause]
right my son Travis ran away in anger
and now you're sending Billy to a home
what happened to us I miss us
Andy baby don't you see this is us mrs.
kunen
new this spring on TBS
director and starring the new movie I
started for Bradley Cooper's here
through the card next time if I guess
superorganism is going to play
[Applause]
you